we uh first did a test run I think in
2019 about 50 and we've been doing it
for four years now always trying to make
the methodology more and more precise to
better reflect the actual environment at
particular schools
um and this year the number one school
is Michigan Technological University
which was a a nice surprise uh the
number two school was actually Auburn
University
um which was nice to see in the top 10
the most well-known prestigious school
is actually UVA which did really well
this year University of Chicago was not
happy that they weren't number one but
University of Chicago is 13 and they had
been number one or in the top three
three years prior to that really so can
you explain it's almost surprising is it
because of uh like the really strong
economics departments and things like
this or what why they had a case
involving a student they wouldn't
recognize a chapter of Turning Point USA
and they made a very classic argument
um that we and classic in the back bad
way that we hear campuses across the
country oh we have a campus Republicans
so we don't need this additional
conservative group and we're like no I'm
sorry like we've seen dozens and dozens
if not hundreds of attempts to get this
one particular
um conservative student uh student group
uh dercognized or not recognized and so
we told them like listen this like uh we
told them at fire that uh you know we
consider this serious and they wouldn't
recognize the group so that that's a
that that's a point down in our ranking
and it was enough to knock them from
they probably would have been number two
in the rankings uh but now they're 13
out of 248 they're still one of the best
schools in the country I have no problem
uh saying that the school that did not
do so well
um at a negative 10.69 negative 10.69
and we rounded up to zero was Harvard
and Harvard uh has been not very happy
with that result the only school to
receive the abyss small ranking yeah and
there are a couple oh Harvard oh Harvard
and there are a couple people who have
actually been really I think making a
mistake by getting very Harvard
um sounding by being like I've had
statisticians look at this and they they
think your methodology is a joke and uh
and like pointing out and this case
wasn't that important and that scholar
wasn't that scholar like one of the
arguments against one of the scholars
that we counted against them for uh
punishing was that that wasn't a very
you know famous or influential scholar
it kind of like so your argument seems
to be snobbery like essentially that
like you you're not understanding our
methodology for one thing and then
you're saying that actually that scholar
wasn't important enough to count and by
the way Harvard
by the way Harvard
um if we yeah if we even if we took all
of your arguments as true even if we
decided to get rid of those two
professors
um you would still be in negative
numbers you would still be dead last you
would still be after Georgetown and Penn
and neither of those schools are good
for freedom of speech I should say the
the bottom five is the University of
Pennsylvania thank you said Penn uh the
University of South Carolina Georgetown
University and Fordham University all
very well earned that they have so many
bad cases at all of those schools what's
the best way to find yourself in the
bottom five if you're a university
what's what's the fastest way to that
negative to that zero a lot of
de-platforming
um that uh when we looked at the bottom
five uh 81 of attempts to get speakers
de-platformed were successful at the
bottom five um there were a couple
schools I think Penn included where
every single attempt every time a
student like objected a student group
objected to that speaker coming they
canceled this the speech and I think I
think Georgetown was 100 success right I
think Penn had 100 success rate I think
Harvard did stand up for a couple but
mostly uh people got D platform there as
well